the next one we got is do not get into
long-term relationships with attention
seeking women in your life
that's red flag number let me see it on
my list over here I always have these
things in front of me so you can
validation attention number 13.
um yeah it's funny because when I did
this presentation with a slideshow this
was this was a few years before
I started writing the book I think and
um
that definitely made it in and there is
a big one because you know in today's
world women well
attention is the currency of the realm
for women right it is the coin of the
realm for them you remove attention from
them you like any time a guy's done a
soft decks she misbehaves you just go
silent you don't text her you don't call
her for a couple of days liter mill on
it she calls her you don't answer she
texts you know you don't answer
they they often just will self-correct
or they'll come back in your frame and
you know try to understand why I try to
do some work usually you know the good
ones anyway but when you deal with these
women that are constantly seeking
attention online from other sources how
do you how do you compete with that
right like how do you as a guy that she
might even come to at some point and
said yo I'm off I dig your Vibe don't
want to share with anybody or do we
stand you know like the talk sort of
thing but she's still seeking attention
online and validation from other guys
when things don't go her way which they
will invariably at some point and she's
not getting the attention from you and
she's used to getting elsewhere like IE
online maybe with a big Instagram
following or something like that guess
where she's going to go right women will
go immediately to get attention and
validation elsewhere when you take it
away from them and I've seen women do
some nefarious things where it's like
you know uh it's not going their way but
they're so used to getting loads of
attention they immediately you know will
go to their phone their box of dicks and
then they'll start messaging and in some
cases not one guy I heard a recent story
where it was like every dude that was in
her you know this chick's phone
um and it's you know it's a shame but it
but it's a red flag and I think if you
vet for these before you invite a chick
like this in your life on a long-term
basis
um the chances you have in a good
experience in an LTR grow up from go up
dramatically I tell guys all the time
look you know you can invite crazy in
your life I see lots of guys do it but
don't don't expect a pleasant peaceful
enjoyable Life along the way you're
gonna have drama
and you know when you invite a woman
that seeks attention online then that's
part of the drama that's going to come
with it you're going to be called
controlling you're going to be called
abusive you're going to be called all
kinds the name insecure you know for
maybe putting your foot down and and
saying something but the time to do it
and again I'll reiterate this and
there's really nothing more to expand on
than just this the time to do it is
you're spinning plates cream Rises at
the top you know this the scald knocks
on you and she's like yo where do we
stand
um you know I don't want to share you I
like where this is going blah blah that
sort of stuff and then that's when you
kind of sit back and you go oh okay well
that's interesting because I you know
I've been seeing you for a while too and
I like this and where it's going but
I noticed on your social media uh you
use it to seek a lot of validation
attention online and I just can't take a
girl like that seriously especially on
an exclusive basis right and then you
can leave the ball in their court it's
like well well like what do you want me
to do well what do you need Instagram
for you know are you selling anything I
don't know so make it private or shut it
down right you know it's as simple as
that
um you got anything to add on that one
no it's great I think the only thing
that I would add is that you know a lot
of guys love this meme of holding women
accountable and
this doesn't really work you stated it
perfectly it only really works to a
certain point she has to be invested in
you you guys had to been together you
had to have slept together you had to
spend good time together and she has to
be into you and she wants to move things
to the next level but so many guys that
meet a girl like on the first date
they're like oh yeah like you know how
am I going to take you seriously if your
Instagram's not on private so well she
goes I don't give a [__] dude like okay
bye like so yeah
right she has other options and she's
not invested in you so that's that's
that's a key step that a lot of guys
miss is that a lot of these women are
not going to be invested in you and so
this whole compliant goodbye thing is
not going to work but if you get to a
point where now she's saying yeah like
let's let's take the next step and as
long as it's with the chick you think
let's say this too as long as you think
it's with the chick that you want to
take the next step with if you're just
enjoying spinning hair as a plate and
you don't see that she is there's ever a
world that you're going to elevate her
to that next level then at that point
you kind of got a decision to make some
guys are of the school where they say
whenever like she can leave anytime you
know it's never going to change or some
guys say well maybe she sees me as our
hypergamous best so she's never going to
leave unless I make her so but you know
as long as it's a girl that you're
you're cool with and you think an LTR is
in the cards then then yeah have that
conversation by all means
absolutely I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full-length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out